SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. ALVARADO. GIL ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ DALLEY. DODD. DURAZZO
EGGMAN. GLASER. GONZALEZ. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES. LAIRD LIMON.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR MIN. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA. BOGUE.
PADILLA PORTANTINO. ROTH. RUBIO
SATO. SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
STERN. UMBERG. WAHAB WIENER.
WILK MEMBERS. THE QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR
GUESTS. BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY. PLEASE RISE. WE'LL
BE LED IN PRAYER TODAY BY OUR
CHAPLAIN, SISTER MICHELLE
GORMAN, AFTER WHICH WE'RE GOING
TO ASK YOU TO REMAIN STANDING
FOR THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG. THANK YOU. SO LET US
GATHER IN THE PRESENCE OF OUR
GOD, WHOM WE OFTEN CALL FATHER
BELATED FATHER'S DAY AND
JUNETEENTH, THE DAY WE CELEBRATE
THE END OF SLAVERY, THE DAY WE
MEMORIALIZE THOSE WHO OFFERED US
HOPE FOR THE FUTURE, AND THE DAY
WHEN WE RENEW OUR COMMITMENT TO
THE STRUGGLE FOR FREEDOM. ANGELA
DAVIS, GRACIOUS AND MERCIFUL
GOD, AS WE CELEBRATE JUNETEENTH
THIS WEEK, WE GIVE THANKS FOR
THE HOPE AND PERSEVERANCE OF THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN PEOPLE WHO
CONTINUE TO CONTRIBUTE
GENEROUSLY TO THE ADVANCEMENT OF
SOCIETY. MAY ALL OF US
CELEBRATE, REMEMBER, AND ACT ON
THE WORDS OF CIVIL RIGHTS LEADER
HOWARD THURMAN WHEN HE SAYS,
LOOK WELL TO THE GROWING EDGE
ALL AROUND US, WORLDS ARE DYING
AND NEW WORLDS ARE BEING BORN.
THIS IS THE BASIS OF HOPE. IN
MOMENTS OF DESPAIR, THE
INCENTIVE TO CARRY ON WHEN TIMES
ARE OUT OF JOINT LOOK WELL TO
THE GROWING EDGE. AND SO, LOVING
GOD, MAY WE NOT CLOSE OUR EYES
TO OUR GROWING EDGES AND THE
LESSONS OF JUNETEENTH. LET US
NOT MAKE ANYONE WAIT FOR THE
FREEDOM TO LIVE IN THEIR OWN
TRUTH AND INTEGRITY. TURN OUR
GOOD INTENTIONS INTO ACTS OF
JUSTICE AND REPARATION FOR THE
FAILURES OF THE PAST. AND MAY WE
LEARN TO ACTIVELY CELEBRATE THE
FREEDOM FROM OPPRESSION IN OF
EACH AND EVERY PERSON. THIS WE
ASK IN YOUR NAME. AMEN.
REMEMBER, PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. CGRTS
REPUBLIC, FOR WHICH IT STANDS.
ONE NATION UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE. JUSTICE. ALL RIGHT,
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
IMMEDIATELY INTO PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR. WE HAVE SENATOR
PADILLA WITH GUEST. HE WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE AT THIS TIME,
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU
TO PROVIDE YOUR ATTENTION TO
SENATOR PADILLA. SENATOR PADILLA
, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
ESTEEMED COLLEAGUES, I REALLY AM
EXCITED TO MAKE TAKE A MINUTE TO
JUST GIVE MAKE A WELCOME OF SOME
FAMILY MEMBERS OF MINE. I AM
JOINED THIS MORNING BY FIRST MY
DAUGHTER, ASHLEY PADILLA GOINS.
MY FIRST GRANDSON, WHO IS SHE IS
HOLDING ETHAN NELSON GOINS. MY
SON IN LAW, NELSON PADILLA
GOINS, AND MY BABY SISTER, MISS
KIMBERLY ROWE. NOW ASHLEY IS A
PROUD AZTEC AND GRADUATE OF THE
BIDEN SCHOOL OF POLICY AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF DELAWARE AND IS
PART OF AN ALL FEMALE DRIVEN
POLICY AND POLITICAL CONSULTING
FIRM WITH CLIENTS ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY. MR. NELSON GOINS, MY
SON IN LAW, IS A FORMER NAVAL
OFFICER WHO DID WORK FOR THE D.
TRIPLE C IS A TRUE PAUL. THEY
MET WORKING ON THE CAMPAIGN OF
CONGRESSMAN MIKE LEVIN. NELSON
IS A UCR GRADUATE AND IS NOW A
PROUD LÀ BRUIN STUDYING HEALTH
CARE ADMINISTRATION. SO LOOK
OUT. HERE HE COMES. AND MY
SISTER KIMBERLY, IS A GRADUATE
OF COLORADO STATE AND IS A PROUD
SEIU 2 TO 1 MEMBER IN THE COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO IN THE OFFICE OF
JUVENILE PROBATION. SO PLEASE,
PLEASE, MY FIRST GRANDSON ON MY
DAUGHTER AND SON IN LAW, MY BABY
SISTER. GIVE THEM A BIG
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WELCOME.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE, WE SAY WELCOME TO
THE PADILLA FAMILY.
NEXT UP, WE HAVE SENATOR ROTH
FOR INTRODUCTIONS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. IT'S MY PRIVILEGE
TO INTRODUCE THE THREE LOVES OF
MY LIFE. IT MAY SURPRISE YOU TO
LEARN THAT THE STATE SENATE IS
NOT ON THE LIST. AT LEAST NOT
TODAY. BUT THOSE ON THE LIST ARE
A VERY STRONG WOMAN WHO LEADS ME
EVERY DAY. MY SPOUSE, CINDY, IS
IN THE GALLERY. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, OUR TWO EXCEPTIONAL
GRANDDAUGHTERS, PAIGE, WHO'S AGE
TEN, AND PARKER, WHO IS AGE SIX.
HOW ABOUT A WARM WELCOME FOR
THEM? THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
THE STATE SENATE, WE SAY WELCOME
TO THE ROTH FAMILY. MEMBERS,
WITHOUT OBJECTION, WILL MOVE TO
ASSEMBLY. THIRD READING FILE
ITEM 75. SEEING WHERE SENATOR
CABRERA. OKAY. SHE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2755 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS. AN ACT RELATING TO THE
PAYMENT OF CLAIMS AGAINST THE
STATE, MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFOR AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR CABALLERO,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 2755 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS. AB 2755
IS ONE OF THE BILLS CARRIED BY
THE CHAIRS OF APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEES EACH YEAR TO PROVIDE
PAYMENT AUTHORITY FOR LEGAL
CLAIMS APPROVED BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THIS URGENCY MEASURE
APPROPRIATES $523,000 FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO PAY FOR THE
PREVAILING PARTIES, ATTORNEYS
FEES AND COSTS IN THREE
SPECIFIED CASES, AS IDENTIFIED
IN APPROVED SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS. THESE CLAIMS ARE
BINDING STATE OBLIGATIONS AND
FAILURE TO APPROVE PAYMENTS FOR
THESE CLAIMS WOULD RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL LITIGATION AND STATE
COSTS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AND FALL 75 ALLEN ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE MENGIBAR
I MEN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
NØ. NILO. OCHOA. BORG PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. CIERTO. NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE.
ITEM. NO ALLEN. WE MOVE THE
CALL. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE THE
CALL. ALL RIGHT, NEXT UP IS
GOVERNOR APPOINTMENTS. BUT
BEFORE THAT, WE WANT TO
RECOGNIZE OUR FORMER COLLEAGUE
FROM THE FREMONT AREA. NONE
OTHER THAN SENATOR BOB
WIECKOWSKI UP IN THE GALLERY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
SENATOR GROVE, WE'RE MOVING TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT. SHE'S
PREPARED. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I KNOW
YOU'RE STILL EXCITED ABOUT
SENATOR WIECKOWSKI, BUT.
COLLEAGUES, WE HAVE FILED. ITEM
17 IS THE CONFIRMATION OF THE
FOLLOWING APPOINTMENTS, ARTURO
BARAJAS, RENA, DIMERA. AND
SENATOR GROVE, WE'RE ON FILE
ITEM 13, FIRST FILE ITEM 13.
FIRST APOLOGIZE, SIR. APOLOGIZE.
MR. PRESIDENT, IT WAS BOB
WIECKOWSKI THAT DISTRACTED ME.
GOOD. FILE ITEM 13 IS A
CONFIRMATION OF THE FOLLOWING
IMPORTANT APPOINTMENTS, MARTIN
JUAREZ, FOR THE APPOINTMENT OF
VETERANS BOARD, JUAN CRUZ AND
DAVID SIMMONS AS, TO THE
COMMISSION OF THE TEACHER
CREDENTIALING AND, BENJAMIN
BASKIN. BASKIN TO THE STATE PARK
AND RECREATION COMMISSION. THESE
INDIVIDUALS WERE APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON THE MAY 29TH
ON A50 VOTE. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
APPOINTMENTS HEARING. SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM 13. ALAN
ALVARADO GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DELI. AYE. DODD I
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN I. GLAZER.
AYE. GONZALEZ I GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO I JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LEMON MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR I
MEN. AYE. NEWMAN I NGUYEN I NILO
I. OCHOA BORG. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO I ROTH. AYE RUBIO.
ACIERTO. AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE WIENER.
AYE. WILK. AYE SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN.
LIMON. AYE AYE. STERN AYES 38.
NOES ZERO. THE APPOINTMENTS ARE
CONFIRMED NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 17. SENATOR GIRL. THANK YOU
, MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES,
FILE ITEM 17 IS THE CONFIRMATION
FOR ARTURO BARAJAS, REINA DE MER
AND CHE SALINAS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA EXPOSITION AND STATE
FAIR BOARD OF DIRECTORS,
CATALINA CIFUENTES, DOCTOR
SHANNON GARY AND ANGEL RODRIGUEZ
FOR THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
AND JUDITH FREEMAN FOR
APPOINTMENT TO THE OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH APPEALS BOARD.
THESE APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON A50
VOTE ON JUNE 5TH. AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
APPOINTMENTS ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? HEARING.
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM 17.
ALAN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DELI.
AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MINH. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE.
OCHOA AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE WIENER.
AYE. WILK. AYE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN AYE. STERN H 39 NOES. ZERO.
THE APPOINTMENTS ARE CONFIRMED
NOW. MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTIONS
WILL BE TAKEN UP THE FOLLOWING
RESOLUTION. OUT OF ORDER TODAY
WILL FIRST HAVE FILE ITEM. 30
SCR 150. AND THEN WE'LL TAKE A
FILE ON 32 SCR 98. FIRST UP IS
SENATOR OCHOA BOGH SECRETARY.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 150 BY
SENATOR OCHOA BOGH RELATIVE TO
FLAG DAY. SENATOR FLORES, YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, I RISE TO PRESENT SCR
150, WHICH RECOGNIZES JUNE 14TH,
2024 AS FLAG DAY. ON JUNE 14TH,
7077 247 YEARS AGO THIS PAST
FRIDAY, THE SECOND CONTINENTAL
CONGRESS APPROVED THE NATION'S
FIRST FLAG, WHICH HAD 13 STRIPES
AND A CONSTELLATION OF 13 WHITE
STARS ON A FIELD OF BLUE. SINCE
THEN, AND IN OUR FRONT YARD,
SCHOOLS, STADIUMS AND EVEN ON
THE MOON, AMERICANS HAVE FLOWN
SEVERAL VARIATIONS OF THE FLAG
IN FACT, BETWEEN 1777 AND 1960,
THERE WERE OVER 20 VERSIONS OF
THE AMERICAN FLAG AS A STAR WAS
ADDED EVERY TIME A STATE JOINED
THE UNION. WHILE THE NUMBER OF
FLAGS IN THE FLAG, WHILE THE
NUMBER OF STARS ON THE FLAG MAY
HAVE CHANGED THE IDEALS IT
REPRESENTS HAVE REMAINED THE
SAME. JUSTICE, VIGILANCE, AND
PERSEVERANCE. THESE ARE JUST A
FEW OF THE VALUES OUR FLAG
SYMBOLIZES AS PERMISSION TO
READ. PERMISSION GRANTED. THANK
YOU. IN HIS 1917 FLAG DAY
PROCLAMATION, PRESIDENT WOODROW
WILSON STATED THAT THE FLAG
REPRESENTS OUR UNITY OF POWER,
OUR THOUGHT AND PURPOSE AS A
NATION. IN HIS 1988 FLAG DAY
PROCLAMATION, PRESIDENT RONALD
REAGAN WROTE THAT THE FLAG QUOTE
REMINDS US OF THE COURAGE AND
STEADFASTNESS. STEADFASTNESS OF
THOSE WHO PLEDGED THEIR LIVES,
THEIR FORTUNES, AND THEIR SACRED
HONOR TO FOUND THIS GREAT
EXPERIMENT IN REPUBLICAN
GOVERNMENT. IN HIS 2024 FLAG DAY
PROCLAMATION, PRESIDENT JOSEPH
BIDEN SAID THE FLAG STANDS FOR
THE SACRED IDEA THAT WE ARE ALL
CREATED EQUAL AND DESERVE TO BE
TREATED EQUALLY THROUGH OUR
THROUGHOUT OUR LIVES. SCR 150
CONTINUES THE 75 YEAR TRADITION
OF RECOGNIZING FLAG DAY AND OUR
NATION'S COMMITMENT TO FORM A
MORE PERFECT UNION. THIS
REPUBLIC MAY NOT BE PERFECT, BUT
IT IS INDIVISIBLE. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, IT IS FOR ALL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? SENATOR
RUBIO? THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE, I ALSO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SCR 150, WHICH
RECOGNIZES FLAG DAY. TO ME, IT'S
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
SYMBOLS HERE IN OUR GREAT NATION
THAT UNITES US. AND I CANNOT
HELP BUT THINK OF MY CLASSROOM
FOR 20 YEARS RECITING THE FLAG.
AND I THINK OF OUR STUDENTS WHO
GET TO SEE SO MUCH DIVISION AND
UGLINESS AROUND US. BUT IN THOSE
MOMENTS IN CLASS, WHILE WE'RE
ALL RECITING THE FLAG, AND EVEN
HERE IN THIS FLOOR, WE'RE ALL
EQUAL. WE'RE ALL STANDING WITH
HONOR. WE'RE ALL HONORING THE
FLAG, WHICH AGAIN, IS THAT ONE
SYMBOL THAT CAN UNITE ALL OF US
AND I ALSO THINK OF THAT IMAGE
IN WORLD WAR TWO, IWO JIMA,
WHERE EVERYTHING WAS DARK,
EVERYTHING WAS HAD CRUMBLED, AND
EVERYTHING HAD JUST FALLEN. BUT
OLD GLORY STOOD TALL, IT STOOD
BRAVE. AND IT SHOWED US WHAT
RESILIENCY LOOKED LIKE. SO I
WANT TO JUST ALSO ADD MY VOICE
AND ASK THAT YOU VOTE AYE ON
THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? HEARING? SEEING NONE.
SENATOR BOGUE, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. SECRETARY MEMBERS,
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO FILE ITEM
30 AND SEEING NONE? AYES 39,
NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 32. OH. ALL
RIGHT, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
SENATOR OKOBO, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, I
RISE TO PRESENT SCR 150, WHICH
RECOGNIZES JUNE 4TH. SORRY ARE
YOU'RE INTRODUCING SOMEBODY?
YEAH, I AM INTRODUCING ONE
MOMENT. MY RIGHTS SPEECH, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, I WANT
TO EXTEND A WARM WELCOME TO
KATHLEEN BEALL, A BOARD MEMBER
OF THE REDLANDS AREA HISTORICAL
SOCIETY, WHICH HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN PRESERVING THE
RICH AND DIVERSE HISTORY OF
REDLANDS, A CITY IN MY DISTRICT.
I WAS HONORED TO RECEIVE THEIR
HELP IN HIGHLIGHTING THE LEGACY
OF REDLANDS ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
TEACHER MARY FACKLER IN SCR 150,
RELATIVE TO FLAG DAY. MARY
FLAGLER, WHO TAUGHT A KINGSBURY
SCHOOL FOR $75 A MONTH, IS
ATTRIBUTED WITH STARTING THE
TRADITION OF BEGINNING THE
SCHOOL DAY WITH THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. THE NIGHT THE 1892
VERSION OF THE PLEDGE, WRITTEN
BY MINISTER FRANCIS BELLAMY AND
RECITED BY HER STUDENTS, READ I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO MY FLAG AND
TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION, INDIVISIBLE,
WITH LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR
ALL. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING KATHLEEN BEALL AND
THE REDLANDS AREA HISTORICAL
SOCIETY FOR MORE THAN 50 YEARS
OF CELEBRATING THE HISTORY Kò IN
REDLANDS. THANK YOU. WELCOME TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
ALL RIGHT. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM 32. SENATOR
JONES, ARE YOU PREPARED? HE IS
GETTING THERE. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ SENATE RESOLUTION 98 BY
SENATOR JONES RELATIVE TO SUDDEN
CARDIAC ARREST AWARENESS MONTH.
SENATOR JONES, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
AND MEMBERS, I AM HERE THIS
AFTERNOON AS, PRESENT SENATE
RESOLUTION 98, SUDDEN CARDIAC
ARREST, COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS
SCA. SCA IS A SIGNIFICANT HEALTH
ISSUE HERE IN OUR STATE, RATHER
THAN A TRADITIONAL HEART ATTACK
THAT RESULTS FROM THE BLOCKAGE
OF BLOOD FLOW. SCA OCCUR WHEN
THE HEART SUDDENLY MAL
MALFUNCTIONS AND STOPS BEATING,
DISTURBING THE SCA IS THE
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH AMONG
STUDENT ATHLETES, CLAIMING AN
ESTIMATED 23,000 LIVES ANNUALLY
IN THE UNITED STATES.
CALIFORNIA'S SCA SURVIVAL RATE
IS AN ALARMINGLY LOW, JUST 7.8.
EARLY SYMPTOMS AND FAMILIAL RISK
FACTORS THAT CAN CONTRIBUTE TO
SCA ARE OFTEN MISSED,
UNDERSCORING THE NEED FOR
COMPREHENSIVE CARDIAC SCREENINGS
, ESPECIALLY IN YOUNG PEOPLE.
SCR 98 DESIGNATES OCTOBER AS
SUDDEN CARDIAC AWARENESS MONTH.
SUDDEN CARDIAC ARREST AWARENESS
MONTH TO PROMOTE PROMOTE PUBLIC
EDUCATION ABOUT THIS OFTEN
MISUNDERSTOOD CONDITION AND
PROMOTE THE IMPORTANCE OF
PREVENTIVE SCREENING AND
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THIS AFTERNOON
. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM, SENATOR BECKER? THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE AS A JOINT
AUTHOR, AND WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO FOR
HIGHLIGHTING THE SCREENING
ELEMENTS OF THIS SUDDEN CARDIAC
ARREST IS AN UMBRELLA TERM
THAT'S USED TO DESCRIBE THE
SPONTANEOUS STOPPAGE OF THE
HEART. AND IT'S CHARACTERIZED BY
HIGH MORTALITY, ESPECIALLY IN
OUR YOUTH. THEY'RE OFTEN THE
RESULT OF AN UNDERLYING CAUSE
THAT OFTEN GOES UNDETECTED.
THEREFORE I THEREFORE EARLY
INTERVENTIONS ARE CRITICAL.
THREE STEPS FOR EARLY
INTERVENTION INCLUDE NUMBER ONE
EARLY BYSTANDER NOTIFICATION OF
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES.
NUMBER TWO, ADMINISTRATION OF
HIGH QUALITY CPR. AND THREE, THE
COMBINED USE OF AUTOMATIC
EXTERNAL DEFIBRILLATORS OR AEDS.
AND TAKE THE CASE OF ERIKA
LYONS, A HILLSBOROUGH RESIDENT
TURNED ADVOCATE WHOSE TEENAGE
NEPHEW COLLAPSED WITH A SUDDEN
CARDIAC ARREST AT A LOCAL
BASKETBALL GAME. THEY WERE HERE
LAST YEAR WITH US WHEN WE
CONSIDERED THIS AN AND, HER
NEPHEW WAS LIFE WAS SAVED BY THE
USE OF CPR AND AN AED BEING
CRITICAL. TIME ESTIMATES SUGGEST
THAT FOR EVERY MINUTE CPR DELAY,
THERE'S A 10% REDUCTION IN
SURVIVAL BY DESIGNATING OCTOBER
AS SUDDEN CARDIAC AWARENESS
MONTH, WE CAN BEGIN THE PROCESS
OF COMMUNITY EDUCATION AND
TRAINING TO INCREASE OUR
READINESS AND POWER. BYSTANDERS
WITH A KNOWLEDGE AND TRAINING TO
SAVE LIVES. PLEASE JOIN US IN
APPROVING SCR 98 SR 98. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? HEARING.
SEEING. NONE. SENATOR JONES,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I
WANT TO THANK OUR GOOD COLLEAGUE
FOR JOINING ME TODAY IN SPEAKING
ABOUT SR 98 AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 32. ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. I NEWMAN.
NGUYEN AYE. NILO AYE. OCHOA AYE.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. UMBERG AYE.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE
SENATOR JONES MOVES TO CALL.
NOW. WE'RE MOVING BACK TO
PRIVILEGES ON THE FLOOR. SENATOR
JONES, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. FOR
PURPOSES OF INTRODUCTION. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS,
WE ARE JOINED WITH SOME
ADVOCATES THIS AFTERNOON THAT
ARE WORKING ON THE SUDDEN
CARDIAC ARREST SYNDROME IN HIGH
SCHOOLS. TODAY, WE ARE JOINED BY
SOME DEDICATED ADVOCATES WHO ARE
TIRELESSLY HECTOR PAREDES IS THE
CO-FOUNDER OF THE ERIC PERETTA
SAVE A LIFE FOUNDATION. IN 2009,
HECTOR, HIS 15 YEAR OLD SON ERIC
PASSED AWAY FROM SCA. HECTOR IS
NOW DEDICATED. HIS LIFE TO
RUNNING CARDIAC SCREENING EVENTS
AT MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOLS TO
HOPEFULLY PREVENT OTHER FAMILIES
FROM HAVING TO EXPERIENCE THE
SAME TRAGEDY THAT HIS FAMILY
HAS. WE ARE ALSO JOINED BY
JENNIFER SARMIENTO, THE FOUNDER
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
KYLE J. TAYLOR FOUNDATION.
JENNIFER LOST HER SON KYLE, TO
SCA IN 2018. THROUGH HER
FOUNDATION, SHE HELPS RAISE
AWARENESS AND PROMOTE CARDIAC
SCREENINGS TO PREVENT OTHER
FAMILIES FROM ENDURING A SIMILAR
LOSS. COLLEAGUES, PLEASE JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING THESE TIRELESS
ADVOCATES TODAY. HECTOR PAREDES
AND JENNIFER SARMIENTO.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WERE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WOULD BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MOVING ON TO MOTIONS.
RESOLUTION AND NOTICES. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR JUNE 10TH, 2024 THROUGH JUNE
13TH, 2024 WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
SENATOR DURAZO, YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR, PLEASE PULL FILE ITEM 98
AB 2590 FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE DEATHS WERE NO.
SENATOR LIMON, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR, PLEASE
PULL AB 81. RAMOS OFF THE
INACTIVE FILE. SENATOR LAIRD,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU.
MADAM PRESIDENT, AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR, PLEASE REMOVE
FILE ITEM A 23 AB 1537 FROM THE
INACTIVE FILE. THE DESK HAS
NOTED. SENATOR NILO. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR, PLEASE REMOVE
FILE ITEM 105 AB 801 FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE DESK IS
NOTED. THERE ARE FLOOR
AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK. THEY
WILL BE DEEMED ADOPTED. MOVING
ON TO CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE UNDER SECOND READING FILE,
WE HAVE ITEMS ONE THROUGH 12.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 111.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2348 WITH
AMENDMENTS 2701 WITH AMENDMENTS
2297. SECOND READING WILL BE
DEEMED READ. MOVING ON TO SENATE
THIRD READING. WE HAVE ONE ITEM
FILE ITEM 31. SENATOR BRADFORD,
HE IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 152 BY SENATOR
BRADFORD, RELATIVE TO
JUNETEENTH. SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
RISE PROUDLY TO PRESENT SCR 152
RECOGNIZED THE 115TH AND 59TH, I
SHOULD SAY ANNIVERSARY OF
JUNETEENTH, BETTER KNOWN AS
EMANCIPATION DAY, FREEDOM DAY
AND JUBILEE DAY. ALTHOUGH
SLAVERY, QUOTE UNQUOTE,
OFFICIALLY ENDED IN 1863 WHEN
PRESIDENT LINCOLN SIGNED THE
EMANCIPATION PROCLAMATION,
TECHNICALLY, FOR MANY, IT DIDN'T
END UNTIL TWO AND A HALF YEARS
LATER, WHEN SOME FREED SLAVES
GOT THE WORD. BUT TRUTH BE TOLD,
SLAVERY DID NOT END IN THIS
STATE UNTIL THE AMENDMENT OF THE
13TH AMENDMENT, BECAUSE WHAT THE
EMANCIPATION PROCLAMATION DID
WAS ONLY FREED THOSE SLAVES THAT
WERE IN CONFEDERATE STATES. SO
IF YOU WERE PART OF THE UNION
AND YOU STILL HAD SLAVES, YOU
YOU CONTROLLED YOUR SLAVES UNTIL
THE AMENDMENT, THE 13TH
AMENDMENT WAS AMENDED. SO
JUNETEENTH NOW COMMEMORATES THAT
TWO AND A HALF YEAR DELAY FOR
SOLDIERS TO REACH GALVESTON,
TEXAS. AND IT'S MUCH DEBATE OVER
WHY JUNETEENTH VERSUS JUNE 19TH,
SPECIFICALLY JUNE 19TH, IS WHEN,
THE A MAJOR GENERAL GRANGER
REACHED GALVESTON, BUT THE WORD
STARTED PROGRESSING WESTERLY,
FROM LOUISIANA TO TEXAS,
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN THE 12TH AND
THE 19TH. SO THAT'S WHY
DIFFERENT INDIVIDUALS GOT THE
WORD AT DIFFERENT TIMES. BUT IT
FINALLY ENDED ON JUNE 19TH,
WHERE OVER 250 SLAVES IN TEXAS
WERE NOTIFIED THAT THEY WERE
FREE. AND ALTHOUGH JUNETEENTH
HAS ONLY BEEN A NATIONAL HOLIDAY
SINCE THE 21ST, 2021, I SHOULD
SAY AMERICANS HAVE LONG
CELEBRATED THIS HOLIDAY. THIS
WAS A HOUSEHOLD EVENT FOR ME AND
MY FAMILY. AND MY FAMILY'S FROM
TEXAS. AND UP UNTIL MY FATHER
PASSED, HE WENT BACK TO TEXAS TO
CELEBRATE JUNETEENTH EVERY YEAR.
AND IT'S OFTEN ASSOCIATED WITH
JUNETEENTH WATERMELON RED
HIBISCUS TEA, OR AS MY GREAT
GRANDMOTHER USED TO SAY, RED
SODA POP OR SODA WATER AND RED
VELVET CAKE. AND THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THAT WAS BECAUSE
OF THE BLOOD THAT WE SHED FOR
THIS NATION, AND THAT SYMBOLIZED
THAT BLOOD. AND THAT DAY WAS
ALWAYS COLORFUL WITH MUSIC, WITH
ALL KIND OF FOOD AND FESTIVITIES
. AND THAT'S WHY I HAVE RED ON
THE DAY TO AGAIN CELEBRATE THOSE
COLORS AND THOSE SYMBOLISMS OF
JUNETEENTH AND WHAT IT MEANS.
AND IT'S VITALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE UNDERSTAND, ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF REPARATIONS. JUNETEENTH
IS AN INHERENTLY REMINDER OF THE
NATION'S DARK PAST. THE UNITED
STATES IS A GREAT COUNTRY, BUT
IT'S A GREAT COUNTRY IN LARGE
PART BECAUSE IT WAS BUILT AND
MADE PROSPEROUS FOR OVER 250
YEARS OF SLAVE LABOR BY BLACK
FOLKS WHO LOOK LIKE ME. AND EVEN
THOUGH SLAVERY HAS ENDED ITS
IMPACTS, IMPACTS STILL EXISTS IN
OUR COUNTRY AND OUR STATE TODAY.
THAT'S NOT JUST MY CLAIM, IT'S
THE BELIEF OF MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH OVER 60% WHO
REGISTERED TO VOTE STATED SO IN
A POLL. BERKELEY CONDUCTED A
POLL IN 2023, AND THEY ASKED,
WHAT IS THE LEGACY OF SLAVERY
TODAY? AND 60% STILL SELL. IT
WAS FELT. IT WAS, FELT TODAY 158
YEARS LATER. AND BOTH HEALTH
DISPARITIES, WEALTH DISPARITIES,
EDUCATION DISPARITIES, MASS
INCARCERATION, THÀNH HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION, INCLUDING
POLICIES LIKE, RESTRICTIVE
COVENANTS AND REDLINING AND
RACIALLY MOTIVATED TAKING BY
EMINENT DOMAIN, HAVE HARMED AND
HELD BLACK AMERICANS FROM
REALIZING THE AMERICAN DREAM
FREELY AND FULLY FOR OVER 200
YEARS. SO JUNETEENTH IS A TIME
WHEN ALL AMERICANS SHOULD LOOK
NOT ONLY AROUND, BUT INSIDE
THEIR HEARTS AND UNDERSTAND THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE, THE CELEBRATIONS AND THE
LOSSES AND RECOGNIZE RECOGNIZE
THE LASTING HARMS OF SLAVERY.
DECADES OF RACIST LAWS AND
POLICIES, WHICH ARE TASK FORCE
CLEARLY SPELLED OUT ON THE TWO
YEARS ON THE REPARATIONS TASK
FORCE. IT'S THE REASON WHY I'M
NOW WORKING SO HARD TO PASS
REPARATIONS LEGISLATION. AND I
THINK SO MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
WHO HAVE SUPPORTED IT, THIS FAR.
AND TO THE DESCENDANTS OF SLAVES
WHO DESERVE THIS HARD WORK ON
OUR PART, OFTEN SAY REPARATIONS
IS NOT A DEBT OWED. IT'S NOT
CHARITY, IT'S NOT A HANDOUT.
IT'S NOT A GIFT. IT'S WHAT IS
PROMISED, WHAT IS SOLD, AND WHAT
IS 160 YEARS OVERDUE. I HOPE
THIS JUNETEENTH HOLIDAY WILL
LEAD TO A MORE HONEST EDUCATION
AND DISCUSSION AND UNDERSTANDING
OF OUR HISTORY AND THE REAL
HISTORY, NOT THE WHITEWASH
VERSION THAT WE OFTEN TEACH IN
OUR SCHOOLS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE TO SCR 152. THANK
YOU SENATOR. SENATOR PADILLA,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT.
TODAY I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE LGBTQ
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF SCR 152,
WHICH RECOGNIZES AND
COMMEMORATES JUNE 19TH AS
JUNETEENTH IN CALIFORNIA, A
HISTORIC DATE ON WHICH THE LAST
ENSLAVED BLACK AMERICANS WERE
FREED IN 2020 FOR THE 159TH
ANNIVERSARY OF JUNETEENTH, WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CRITICALLY EXAMINE OUR COUNTRY'S
SHAMEFUL HISTORY OF SLAVERY AND
ENGAGE IN A MEANINGFUL
DISCUSSION ON HOW THIS HISTORY
CONTINUES TO IMPACT US EVEN
TODAY. WITHOUT THE NATIONAL AND
STATEWIDE RECOGNITION OF
JUNETEENTH, WE CANNOT PROUDLY
CLAIM THE VALUES OF LIBERTY AND
FREEDOM, NOT WHEN THESE SAME
VALUES WERE DENIED AND DELAYED
TO ENSLAVE BLACK AMERICANS. 159
YEARS AGO, AND NOT WHEN LIBERTY
AND FREEDOM ARE CONTINUOUSLY
DENIED TO BLACK AMERICANS TODAY,
AS A MEMBER OF THE LGBTQ CAUCUS,
I MUST ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE HOW
LGBTQ PLUS BLACK AMERICANS ARE
CORNERSTONES OF OUR COMMUNITY.
THEY WERE THE DRIVING FORCE
BEHIND THE FIRST PRIDE. THEY ARE
AT THE FOREFRONT OF OUR
COMMUNITY'S CULTURE. THEY ARE
COURAGEOUS ADVOCATES AND
OUTSPOKEN ACTIVISTS. BUT LET US
TAKE A MINUTE TO CELEBRATE BLACK
QUEER JOY AND EXCELLENCE. JUST
LAST WEEK, THIS BODY HAD THE
HONOR OF RECOGNIZING AND
CELEBRATING AN INCREDIBLE BLACK
TRANS TRAILBLAZER IN SIR LADY
JAVA, A PIONEERING TRANSGENDER
ENTERTAINER, ENTERTAINER AND
ACTIVIST WHO BROKE BARRIERS IN
THE 1960S AND 1970S BY
CHALLENGING DISCRIMINATORY LAWS
AND PRACTICES IN LOS ANGELES.
HER COURAGEOUS EFFORTS AGAINST
UNJUST REGULATIONS SIGNIFICANTLY
ADVANCED TRANSGENDER RIGHTS AND
CONTINUE TO INSPIRE THE LGBTQ
PLUS COMMUNITY. TODAY HOWEVER,
LGBTQ PLUS BLACK AMERICANS ARE
ALSO THE MOST VULNERABLE AND
UNPROTECTED MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY. AS MANY OF US KNOW,
BLACK TRANS WOMEN FACE HIGH
RATES OF FATAL VIOLENCE. BLACK
LGBTQ+ YOUTH ARE AT A HIGHER
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS. MY CAUCUS
MEMBERS AND I WORK TO AMPLIFY
THE VOICES AND TO ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF BLACK LGBT. Q PLUS
AMERICANS. THE RECOGNITION OF
JUNETEENTH IS A STEP TOWARDS
ENSURING THAT BLACK AMERICAN
HISTORY, REAL HISTORY IS
REMEMBERED AS AMERICAN HISTORY.
I THANK YOU, AND I URGE AN AYE
VOTE. SENATOR DORADO, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. MADAM PRESIDENT, ON
BEHALF OF THE LATINO LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS, IT IS MY HONOR TO RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SCR 152
JUNETEENTH, ALSO KNOWN AS
FREEDOM DAY OR EMANCIPATION DAY,
IS SYMBOLIC IN THAT IT IS
CONSIDERED THE DATE WHEN THE
LAST SLAVES IN AMERICA WERE
FREED ALMOST TWO AND A HALF
YEARS AFTER PRESIDENT LINCOLN
ISSUED THE EMANCIPATION
PROCLAMATION. I USED THE TERM
FREED LOOSELY BECAUSE WHAT WAS
OUTLAWED AND WHAT ACTUALLY
OCCURRED WERE TWO VERY DIFFERENT
REALITIES IS THE ABOLITION OF
SLAVERY DID NOT BRING EQUALITY.
JUNETEENTH. JUNETEENTH HAPPENED
89 YEARS AFTER US INDEPENDENCE
DAY AND IT WOULD BE ANOTHER 100
YEARS BEFORE THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT GAINED TRACTION AND
STARTED TO RIGHT THE WRONG OF
SEGREGATION. UNDERSTANDING OUR
PAST AND ACKNOWLEDGING HEROES IN
OUR DIVERSE COMMUNITIES HAS ONLY
SERVED TO STRENGTHEN THE TIES
BETWEEN EVERY RESIDENT OF THIS
STATE. AS WE CELEBRATE
JUNETEENTH AND ASK ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO HONOR AND
REFLECT ON THE SIGNIFICANT
ACHIEVEMENTS AND THE IMPACT
AFRICAN AMERICANS HAVE PLAYED IN
THE EVOLUTION ON THE SUCCESS OF
THIS NATION, AFRICAN AMERICAN
CULTURE HAS INFLUENCED EVERY
ASPECT OF AMERICAN LIFE. FOR
EXAMPLE, FREDERICK MCKINLEY
JONES LEFT HIS INDELIBLE MARK
WITH THE DEVELOPMENT OF
REFRIGERATION EQUIPMENT IN THE
1930S. HIS CREATION, THE THERMO
KING, ALLOWED PEOPLE TO EAT
FRESH FOOD YEAR ROUND. 1991 HE
BECAME THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN TO RECEIVE THE NATIONAL
MEDAL OF TECHNOLOGY AND CONSIDER
THE IMPACT THAT MARK DEAN HAD ON
OUR LIVES WHEN, AFTER EARNING A
DOCTORATE AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY
, HE HELPED INVENT IBM'S
ORIGINAL PERSONAL COMPUTER AND
THE PC COLOR MONITOR. THERE ARE
COUNTLESS, COUNTLESS EXAMPLES
THAT WE COULD ALL PROVIDE OF
LEADERS AND PIONEERS THAT HAVE
IMPACTED AND CONTINUE TO
INFLUENCE OUR LIVES, BUT I
CHALLENGE YOU TO USE THIS TIME
TO RESEARCH, TO LISTEN, AND TO
TAKE IN THE STORIES THAT HAVE
LARGELY BEEN UNTOLD BUT HAVE
SHAPED OUR VERY LIVES. WITH
THAT, I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP. SENATOR
MIN, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FROM GARDENA
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD ON
BEHALF OF THE ASIAN AMERICAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS, WE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT OF SCR 152 TO RECOGNIZE
JUNETEENTH EACH YEAR ON JUNE
19TH, WE COMMEMORATE THIS DAY,
WHICH REALLY MARKED THE LAST THE
END OF THE LAST VESTIGES OF
SLAVERY IN THIS COUNTRY. AND TO
THINK THAT THIS WAS JUST OVER
170 YEARS AGO, NOT THAT LONG AGO
, IN TERMS OF OUR COUNTRY'S
HISTORY, IS REALLY A STARK
REMINDER OF THIS SHAMEFUL PERIOD
IN OUR COUNTRY'S HISTORY. THIS
IS A DAY THAT IS ONE OF
CELEBRATION, BUT I THINK IT'S
ALSO A DAY THAT WE NEED TO KEEP
IN OUR HEARTS TO REMEMBER, TO
REMIND OURSELVES OF THE HISTORY
OF THIS COUNTRY, TO HONOR THE
CONTRIBUTIONS AND SACRIFICES AND
HISTORIES OF THE BLACK AND
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITIES,
THE ROLE THEY'VE PLAYED IN
SHAPING OUR NATION AND OUR STATE
OF CALIFORNIA, BUT ALSO TO
REMIND US OF, THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY, THE
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY, THE MAJORITY OF
CITIZENS, I SHOULD SAY, THOUGHT
THAT IT WAS OKAY TO OWN THE
LABOR AND THE LIVES OF OTHER
PEOPLE AND TO HONOR THAT IN OUR
HEARTS, TO TRY TO CONTINUE THE
FIGHT FOR JUSTICE AND PROGRESS,
FOR DIVERSITY, EQUITY AND
INCLUSION. WE CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO COMBAT RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION OF EVERY TYPE AND
TO TRY TO PUSH FORWARD FOR THE
IDEALS OF THIS COUNTRY. IT'S AN
HONOR FOR THE AAPI LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS TO STAND IN SUPPORT OF
JUNETEENTH AND TO REAFFIRM OUR
SOLIDARITY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS, AS
WELL AS THE BLACK AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY AS A WHOLE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON SB, SCR 152. SENATOR WIENER
AYE. THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TODAY AS
CO-CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS AND
SUPPORT OF SCR 152, HONORING AND
RECOGNIZING JUNETEENTH AND THE
END OF SLAVERY IN THE UNITED
STATES IS ESSENTIAL, BOTH AS A
CELEBRATION OF THE DISTANCES WE
HAVE COME AS A COUNTRY, BUT ALSO
AS A RECKONING WITH THE HURDLES
WE STILL MUST OVERCOME, ON
EMANCIPATION DAY, WE HAVE
CHERISHED HAVE A CHERISHED
OPPORTUNITY TO CELEBRATE THE
SURVIVAL OF BLACK AMERICANS
ACROSS HISTORY, JUNETEENTH IS A
CHANCE TO LEARN ABOUT THE BLACK
EXPERIENCE IN AMERICA. FROM THE
ARRIVAL OF SLAVES IN 1619 TO THE
LIBERATION MOVEMENT THAT HAS
BEEN PRESENT SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF OUR COUNTRY. AND WE MUST BE
INTENTIONAL IN LEARNING ABOUT
THE TRIALS AND THE JOYS OF THE
BLACK COMMUNITY. AND WHILE THIS
HOLIDAY IS AN OPPORTUNITY, IT'S
BY NO MEANS SHOULD PRECLUDE US
FROM INCLUDING THIS LEARNING
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY HAS A HISTORY OF
CELEBRATING WITH JOY AFTER
SUBJUGATION AND SUFFERING.
SURVIVAL AND COMMUNITY ARE
INCUMBENT IN FINDING SPACE TO BE
OUR FULL SELVES, TO CLAIM OUR
HUMANITY, EVEN WHEN THAT
HUMANITY IS DENIED US.
JUNETEENTH IS A TESTAMENT,
TESTAMENT TO THIS AXIOM THAT BY
CELEBRATING THE LIBERATION AND
DIGNITY OF BLACK LIFE, WE TAKE A
COLLECTIVE STEP TOWARD MENDING
THE WORLD. THE JEWISH VALUE OF
TIKKUN OLAM. LAST YEAR, AS WE
COMMEMORATED THIS HOLIDAY ON THE
FLOOR SAU, I SPOKE OF THE
RECENTLY DEPARTED HARRY
BELAFONTE, A SHARED CHAMPION OF
THE BLACK AND JEWISH COMMUNITIES
WHO HAD RECENTLY PASSED THIS
YEAR. I'M THINKING ABOUT THE
WAYS IN WHICH OUR JEWISH
COMMUNITY HAS GROWN. EARLIER
THIS YEAR, JENNIE ASHER BECAME
THE FIRST ORDAINED CANTOR WHO
WAS A BLACK AMERICAN WOMAN. FOR
THOSE WHO ARE UNAWARE, MUSIC
PLAYS A CENTRAL ROLE IN JEWISH
WORSHIP, AND THE CANTOR IS AN
IMPORTANT LEADER IN OUR
CONGREGATIONS. ALONG WITH THE
RABBI, WE'RE FORTUNATE TO SEE
THE DIVERSITY OF OUR JEWISH
COMMUNITY REFLECTED IN OUR
SPIRITUAL LEADERS. I'M HONORED
TO VOTE AYE ON THIS RESOLUTION.
SENATOR GROVE, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I TOO, RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SCR 152. AND, YOU
KNOW, HONORING THE RESILIENCE
AND THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF BLACK
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAD
PARTICIPATED IN THE BUILDING OF
THIS NATION IN OUR DISTRICT, WE
CELEBRATED WITH A LOT OF
DIFFERENT EVENTS THROUGHOUT THE
COMMUNITY WHERE BLACK LEADERSHIP
IN OUR COMMUNITY CAME TOGETHER
AND LIKE EDWARD SHAN ROBINSON,
THE PRESIDENT OF OUR BLACK
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE, HAD A
WONDERFUL GALA, A UNITY GALA,
VIBES AND VOICES AND UNITY GALA,
WHERE SEVERAL LEADERS IN OUR
COMMUNITY WERE HONORED FOR THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR COMMUNITY.
WHEN YOU HAVE JAVON DAINGERFIELD
HONORED FOR WHAT HE DOES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S AN OUTREACH TO
THE BLACK COMMUNITY SO THAT THAT
THE NEEDS IN THAT COMMUNITY CAN
BE MET. BIANCA HAYES DOES ALL
THESE HAIRCUTS AND FREE THINGS
FOR KIDS JUST TO BE ABLE TO
CELEBRATE, YOU KNOW, THAT WHAT
SHE HAS TO OFFER TO THE
COMMUNITY AS WELL, MICHAEL
BOWERS AND DRACO MATTHEWS ARE
LEADING A WAY OF MENTORSHIP AND
INVESTING IN THE NEXT GENERATION
TO SHOW SUCCESS WHEN THEY TAKE
THESE YOUNG BLACK STUDENTS THAT
ARE GOING INTO THE COUNTRY,
CLUBS AND THEIR PICTURES ARE ON
THE WALL, AS THE PRESIDENTS ARE
ORGANIZATIONS OF THE COUNTRY
CLUBS, THEY SEE PROMISE AND A
WAY TO GET THERE. AND I KNOW
THAT THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
MISTAKES THAT HAVE MADE IN THE
PAST, BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT I
HAVE A DISTRICT THAT IS REALLY
WORKING HARD FOR UNITY AND
MAKING SURE THAT THE FUTURE IS
BRIGHTER AND BETTER. WE'VE GOT
KATIE, I MEAN, AND THOSE ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ADULTS. I
HAVE KATIE JOHNSON AND NATASHA
KENDRICK, JOHNSON'S DAUGHTER,
AND SHE IS 18 YEARS OLD. SHE'S
INVOLVED IN MANY NONPROFITS. SHE
DOES A LOT OF INCREDIBLE THINGS
FOR OUR COMMUNITY. SHE'S SHE HAS
ASPIRATIONS TO COME HERE AND BE
A SENATOR ONE DAY. AND SHE IS
JUST ONE OF THE MOST INCREDIBLE
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT YOU'LL EVER
MEET IN YOUR LIFE. AND I JUST
THANK THEM FOR THE CELEBRATION,
THE CULTURE, THE HERITAGE,
EVERYTHING THAT THEY BRING TO
THIS JUNETEENTH CELEBRATION AND
MAKING SURE THAT THE HISTORY OF
JUNETEENTH IS TOLD AND WHAT IT
IS, AND THE HISTORICAL VALUE OF
THIS SPECIAL DAY. AND I JUST
THANK YOU FOR THIS RESOLUTION
BEING BROUGHT FORTH. SCR 152 AND
URGENT, I VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR GROVE, SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AND I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES TODAY FOR
THEIR KIND WORDS AND HISTORICAL,
MILESTONES LIFTED UP IN TERMS OF
JUNETEENTH AND THE SIGNIFICANCE
TO CALIFORNIA AND THIS COUNTRY.
AND I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF SCR 152
THAT RECOGNIZE JUNE 19TH AS OUR
JUNETEENTH DAY IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THIS GREAT NATION, WE
CELEBRATE JUNETEENTH BECAUSE, AS
MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM GARDENA
SAID, IN 1865, TWO AND A HALF
YEARS AFTER PRESIDENT LINCOLN
SIGNED THE EMANCIPATION
PROCLAMATION, IT REPRESENTS
JUNETEENTH, THE REAL DECLARATION
OF INDEPENDENCE FOR BLACK
AMERICANS WHO WERE FINALLY FREED
FROM THE CHAINS OF CHATTEL
SLAVERY. AND THOUGH IT WOULD
TAKE ANOTHER 100 YEARS BEFORE
BLACK AMERICANS WOULD BE GRANTED
FULL RIGHTS THROUGH THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT AND DISMANTLE
THE BLACK CODES AND JIM CROW AND
BRUTAL RACIAL DISCRIMINATION.
JUNETEENTH REALLY MARKS FOR ALL
OF US AN UNFOLDING OF THE
DEFINITION OF AMERICAN FREEDOM.
WHAT IT MEANS TO BE IN THE LAND
OF THE FREE, AND WHAT IT MEANS
TO FIGHT AND BE BRAVE FOR
DEMOCRACY AND FOR FREEDOM FOR
ALL. JUNETEENTH RECOGNIZES THE
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
CONTRIBUTIONS OF ENSLAVED PEOPLE
IN THIS NATION, AND ESTIMATES
$22 BILLION WAS AMASSED ON THE
BACKS OF ENSLAVED MEN, WOMEN AND
CHILDREN, MAKING THE US THE
LARGEST ECONOMIC POWER IN THE
WORLD AND CREATING THE OLDEST
WAGE THEFT CLAIM THAT IS YET TO
BE PAID. AND WE HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE DOING
THE DUE DILIGENCE BY CREATING
OUR REPARATIONS TASK FORCE AND
BEGINNING TO MOVE POLICIES TO
ADDRESS THE WRONG AND TO REPAIR
THE HARM. AND WHILE WE CELEBRATE
JUNETEENTH AS A SYMBOL OF
LIBERATION, THE TRUTH IS THAT
THE LONG STANDING IMPACTS OF
RACISM AND DISCRIMINATION AND
ECONOMIC INJUSTICE DID NOT CEASE
IN 1965. IT IS ONLY GROWN MORE
INSIDIOUS, ANALYZED AND TOUCHING
FAR MORE GENERATIONS AND IT
CONTINUES TO MANIFEST IN OUR
CURRENT CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
IT CONTINUES TO MANIFEST,
MANIFEST WHERE WE SEE BLACK
PEOPLE DISPROPORTIONATELY
TARGETED FOR SURVEILLANCE AND
ARREST IN OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM,
WHERE BLACK STUDENTS REMAIN IN
UNDERSERVED AND POORLY FUNDED
SCHOOLS WITH LACK OF
OPPORTUNITIES. IT'S EVIDENT IN
OUR ECONOMY, WHERE EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION PERSISTS EVEN IN
THIS TIME OF GREAT ECONOMIC
GROWTH. THE WAGE GAP CONTINUES
TO WIDEN, WITH THE US BUREAU OF
STATISTICS LAST SUMMER REPORTING
THAT 90% OF THE NATION'S
UNEMPLOYED ARE BLACK AMERICANS.
IN CALIFORNIA, THESE DISPARITIES
BETWEEN BLACK AND WHITE
RESIDENTS ARE DISPROPORTIONATE
GAPS IN LIFE EXPECTANCY, JOB
QUALITY, INCOME INEQUALITY,
HOMELESSNESS, AND OUR ABILITY TO
INVEST IN REAL ENFORCEMENT THAT
PROTECTS THE LIVES OF PEOPLE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES TO HAVE AN
ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITY. BUT THIS
YEAR IN CALIFORNIA, THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS HAS
TAKEN STEPS WITH OUR FIRST
REPARATION PACKAGE. AND I WANT
TO RECOGNIZE SO MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES FOR HAVING COURAGE
AND SUPPORTING THIS PACKAGE THAT
SEEKS TO RESTORE BLACK
CALIFORNIANS. AND BY DOING THAT,
WE STRENGTHEN ALL OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT'S WHY THIS JUNETEENTH
IS, IS, IS AN ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT HISTORIC LANDMARK,
BECAUSE WE ARE CALLING NOT JUST
ON CALIFORNIA TO STAND UP, BUT
WE ARE A MODEL TO THE WORLD AS
NEW YORK HAS COMMENCED ITS FIRST
TASK FORCE AS PLACES LIKE
ILLINOIS AND EVEN AS FAR AS
GHANA ARE LOOKING AT REPARATIONS
AND WHAT CALIFORNIA WILL DO TO
ADDRESS HISTORIC DISCRIMINATION
AND INEQUALITY, WE ARE HONORING
THE SPIRIT OF JUNETEENTH IN THE
WORK THAT WE DO HERE, BY WORKING
TOGETHER TO BUILD A MORE JUST
AND EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
AND TO REPAIR THE HARMS OF THE
PAST. AND BY DOING SO, WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE INJUSTICES, BY
TAKING COURAGEOUS STEPS TO
HEALING AND RECONCILIATION AND
BUILDING A BRIGHTER FUTURE FOR
ALL OF CALIFORNIA, AND ENSURING
THAT THE FULFILLMENT OF THE
PROMISE OF THE EMANCIPATION
PROCLAMATION AND OUR
CONSTITUTION ARE REALIZED IN
CALIFORNIA AND LIVES TODAY. AND
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. SEEING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE,
SENATOR BRADFORD, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT, AND
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES, WHETHER IT'S
INDIVIDUAL OR REPRESENTING THEIR
RESPECTIVE ETHNIC CAUCUSES, FOR
YOUR WORDS OF SUPPORT AND
ENCOURAGEMENT AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY, THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS HOLIDAY AND WHAT IT MEANS
TO THIS NATION AND RECOGNIZE
EASING THE HARMS AND THIS
HOLIDAY IS THE FIRST NATIONAL
HOLIDAY AND 38 YEARS. FIRST ONE
TO FOLLOW MARTIN LUTHER KING'S
BIRTHDAY, WHICH WAS PASSED IN
1983. SO IT SHOWS HOW FAR WE
HAVE COME AS A NATION, BUT IT
ALSO SHOWS HOW FAR WE STILL HAVE
TO GO. SO ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS, I WANT YOU
TO RECEIVE THE FLAG THAT'S ON
YOUR DESK AS WELL AS THE POSTER
IN CELEBRATION OF JUNETEENTH AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS
CELEBRATION IS NOT JUST ABOUT A
DAY OFF FOR THOSE. IT'S AGAIN
ABOUT UNDERSTANDING OUR HISTORY.
UNDERSTANDING THE WORK THAT
WE'RE STILL TRYING TO ACHIEVE AS
A STATE, AS A NATION, BUT ALSO
TO RECOGNIZE THE TREMENDOUS
SACRIFICES OF THOSE DESCENDANTS
OF SLAVERY, HERE IN THIS STATE
AS WELL AS THIS COUNTRY. AND I
INVITE EACH AND EVERY ONE OF YOU
ON THIS FLOOR ON WEDNESDAY, THE
19 AFTERNOON AT NOON, I SHOULD
SAY, TO COME TO MY OFFICE. WE
WILL BE, DISTRIBUTING RED VELVET
CAKE. SO I WANT YOU ALL TO COME
AND PARTAKE AND UNDERSTAND THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF RED VELVET, NOT
JUST TO HAVE A GOOD DESSERT, BUT
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF WHAT IT
REPRESENTS AS WE CELEBRATE
JUNETEENTH. AND FOR THAT, I ASK
FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE
CORTEZ. AYE. DELI. AYE. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. I'M IN A
NEWMAN. I NGUYEN, I NHIÀU. OKUBO
I PADILLA. I PORTANTINO. I ROTH,
I RUBIO I CIERTO I SKINNER I
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I STERN I
UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK I
. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BLAKE SPEAR NILO
I AYES 39. NÓ ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED AND WE'RE
GOING TO BE LIFTING THE CALLS ON
SOME OF THE PREVIOUS FILE ITEMS.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE HAVE TWO
ITEMS THAT ARE ON CALL. WE'RE
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL ON OUR
FIRST ONE FILE ITEM 75.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. AYE.
BECKER AYE. DALLY JONES. NILO.
NÓ. OCHOA BORG. STERN. AYE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DALLY. JONES. OCHOA. BORG. AYES
33. NOES FOUR. THE MEASURE
PASSES, AYES 34. WHAT WAS THE
COUNT AGAIN? AYE. 34. NOTES FOR
33. AYES 33 NOES. FOUR. ON THE
URGENCY. AYES 33. NOES, FOUR ON
THE MEASURE. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 32. WE'RE
GOING TO LIFT A CALL. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ATKINS
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE STERN. AYE AYES
40. NOES ZERO. SO THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR. THIS WOULD BE THE TIME
FOR ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD
LIKE TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING NO ONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3197 1881 2730. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM 110 OF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ALLEN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE.
OCHOA AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMMER. AYE WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ASHBY.
AYE AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR. AYES 39.
NOES ZERO. THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS APPROVED. NO. EYES 39. NO.
ZERO. CONSENT CALENDAR IS
APPROVED. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. WE HAVE TWO
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR ALVARADO
GIL, FLOOR IS YOURS. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES WILL
BE MEETING IMMEDIATELY AFTER
ADJOURNMENT AT 320. ROOM 2200.
HUMAN SERVICES WILL MEET IN ROOM
22 2200 2200. THANK YOU. 15
MINUTES AFTER ADJOURNMENT,
SENATOR MINH, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THE SENATE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER COMMITTEE
WILL MEET UPON ADJOURNMENT OF
SESSION IN THE SWING SPACE, ROOM
1200. NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER WILL MEET IMMEDIATELY
AFTER ADJOURNMENT IN ROOM 1200,
IN THE SWING SPACE. ALL RIGHT.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE RETURN TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. NOW IS
THE TIME FOR ADJOURNING THE
MEMORIES. FIRST UP, WE HAVE
SENATOR CORTEZ. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. SENATORS, I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A VISIONARY
LEADER AND CIVIL RIGHTS ACTIVIST
, VICTOR GARZA, WHO PASSED AWAY
ON JUNE 6TH AT THE AGE OF 86.
VICTOR WAS AN ADVOCATE AT HEART,
AND HIS UNWAVERING COMMITMENT TO
THE FIGHT FOR CIVIL RIGHTS CAN
BE SEEN TO THIS DAY. AND
EVERYTHING HE'S DONE AS A YOUNG
MAN, HE SERVED AS A WELDER IN
THE UNITED STATES NAVY. HE LATER
WENT ON TO BECOME A MANAGER FOR
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY VETERANS
SERVICES OFFICES, WHERE HE
RECEIVED SEVERAL AWARDS FOR HIS
ADVOCACY FOR VETERANS. IN 1988,
VICTOR FOUNDED LA RAZA ROUND
TABLE TO GIVE LATINO AND MEXICAN
AMERICANS A VOICE IN CREATING
POSITIVE CHANGE ALONGSIDE
COMMUNITY LEADERS AND POLICY
MAKERS. AT ABOUT THAT TIME, HE
BECAME A LONGTIME BOARD MEMBER
AND LEADER AT THE CENTER FOR
TRAINING AND CAREERS IN SAN JOSE
. HE SPENT HIS LIFE FIGHTING FOR
EQUITABLE EMPLOYMENT AND
EDUCATION THÀNH ESPECIALLY FOR
LATINOS. HE FOUNDED MENTORSHIP
PROGRAMS TO HELP LATINO STUDENTS
STRUGGLING IN MATH AND ENGLISH.
AS THE FIRST LATINO ELECTED TO
THE BOARD OF THE BERRYESSA
SCHOOL DISTRICT, HE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE
SUPERINTENDENT HIRING LATINO
PRINCIPALS, ADMINISTRATORS, AND
TEACHERS. VICTOR'S ADVOCACY
RESULTED IN NATIONWIDE ACCLAIM,
INCLUDING INVITATIONS FROM THE
CLINTON ADMINISTRATION TO
PARTICIPATE IN AN INITIATIVE ON
RACE AND POVERTY AS PART OF A
CONTINGENT OF LATINO LEADERS
VISITED BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION. LATER ON, I WAS
SURPRISED, EVEN HAVING KNOWN HIM
FOR A COUPLE OF DECADES WHEN I
STARTED TO REALIZE HIS NATIONAL
REACH AND REPRESENTATION,
ESPECIALLY WHEN HE STARTED TO
INVITE ME ON OUT OF STATE TRIPS
WITH HIM TO VISIT PROGRAMS,
ESPECIALLY PROGRAMS THAT WERE
INTENDED TO REDUCE POPULATIONS
IN JUVENILE HALLS AND CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS IN
PLACES LIKE ARIZONA AND OTHER
PLACES IN THE COUNTRY. HIS
PASSION AND VISION FOR OUR
COMMUNITY HAS LEFT A MARK ON ALL
OF CALIFORNIA. AND AS I SAID IN
OTHER STATES ACROSS THE UNION,
HE WILL CONTINUE TO GUIDE US FOR
YEARS TO COME. AND WE LOST A
REAL GIANT. BUT HIS LEGACY WILL
LIVE ON THE WORK WE DO TO CREATE
A FAIRER, MORE JUST SOCIETY. NOT
JUST IN SAN JOSE OR SANTA CLARA
COUNTY, BUT AS I SAID, ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND IN SEVERAL OTHER
STATES AS WELL. VICTOR COULD
CONVENE ANYBODY AT ANY TIME, NOT
IN THE SENSE OF BEING A CLASSIC
MEDIATOR OR SOMEBODY WHO USED
SUGAR INSTEAD OF SOME KIND OF A
STICK. HE DEMANDED THAT PEOPLE
CONVENE. THAT'S WHAT HE DID. AND
THEY DID. IT DIDN'T MATTER IF
THE INDIVIDUAL WAS A MAYOR OR A
POLICE CHIEF OR SOMEBODY WHO
NEEDED TO FLY IN FROM LOS
ANGELES INTO THE BAY AREA. FOR
EXAMPLE, WHEN VICTOR SAID, WE'RE
PUTTING A GROUP TOGETHER TO
BRING JUSTICE, EVERYBODY SHOWED
UP. HE SURVIVED BY HIS FIVE
CHILDREN, SEVERAL GRANDCHILDREN
AND HIS SIBLINGS. MR. PRESIDENT,
A THANK YOU TODAY FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO HIS
LEGACY AND ASK THAT WE ADJOURN
IN HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR CORTEZ. WE ASK THAT YOU
BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO HE CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. AND WE
THANK HIM FOR HIS SERVICE. NEXT
UP, WE HAVE SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES, TODAY I RISE TO
HONOR THE LIFE AND MEMORY OF
MARTY SCHRENK. MARTY WAS A
FIXTURE IN DEMOCRATIC POLITICS
IN ORANGE COUNTY. ACTUALLY
DESCRIBING HER AS A FIXTURE
DOESN'T DO HER JUSTICE. MARTY
WAS IS THE BACKBONE OF THE
PARTY. IN THE DAYS WHEN ORANGE
COUNTY HAD NO ELECTED DEMOCRATS
AT THE SUPERVISORIAL LEGISLATIVE
OR CONGRESSIONAL LEVEL, THAT'S
WHERE MARTY WAS WHEN WE MET IN A
PHONE BOOTH WITH 4 OR 5 PEOPLE.
ONE OF THEM THERE WAS MARTY AND
HER HUSBAND, RICHARD, SHE WAS
BORN ON DECEMBER 28TH, 1937, IN
KANSAS CITY, MISSOURI, TO PAUL
AND ELIZABETH HAFNER. SHE WOULD
MOVE TO CALIFORNIA WITH HER
FAMILY WHEN SHE WAS FIVE. SHE
BEGAN HER VOLUNTEER CAREER IN
1960, REGISTERING VOTERS FOR
JOHN KENNEDY'S CAMPAIGN, AND SHE
WOULD NEVER STOP AFTER THAT. SHE
MET HER HUSBAND, RICHARD
SCHRENK, IN 1972, WHEN SHE
RECRUITED HIM TO WALK PRECINCTS
DURING THE GEORGE MCGOVERN
CAMPAIGN. MARTY, AS I SAID, WAS
THE BACKBONE OF THE PARTY. SHE
VOLUNTEERED ALL HER TIME EXCEPT
FOR WHEN SHE WAS DOING OTHER
GOOD WORKS IN THE COMMUNITY. AT
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
HEADQUARTERS, SHE WAS THE
TREASURER FOR THE FULLERTON
DEMOCRATIC WOMEN. SHE WAS VICE
PRESIDENT OF DEMOCRATS OF NORTH
ORANGE COUNTY, VOLUNTEER
COORDINATOR FOR DEMOCRATIC PARTY
OF NORTH ORANGE COUNTY, AND HAD
A NUMBER OF OTHER POSITIONS WITH
VARIOUS CLUBS AND ASSOCIATIONS.
SHE WAS A MENTOR AND A FRIEND TO
VIRTUALLY EVERY YOUNG DEMOCRAT,
EVERY ASPIRING DEMOCRAT, EVERY
DEMOCRAT OFFICE HOLDER FROM 1970
UNTIL VERY RECENTLY, INCLUDING
ME, AS A TESTAMENT TO HER
DECADES OF MENTORSHIP, SHE WOULD
MEANT SHE WOULD SHE WOULD REACH
OUT TO YOUNG MEMBERS AND
IDENTIFY THEM FOR FUTURE
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS. SHE WAS
ALSO INVOLVED WITH THE UNITED
FARM WORKERS AND MARCHED
ALONGSIDE HER FRIENDS AND
HEROES, CESAR CHAVEZ AND DOLORES
HUERTA, SOME OF YOU MAY BE OLD
ENOUGH TO REMEMBER THE 1996
CAMPAIGN BETWEEN LORETTA SANCHEZ
AND BOB DORNAN, AND SHE WAS
QUITE MEMORABLE. YOU CAN GOOGLE
THIS, FOR SERENADING BOB DORNAN
WHEN THEY THOUGHT HIS CAREER AND
HIS TIME IN OFFICE WAS WAS OVER
WITH A UNIQUE SERENADE, SHE
ENDED EVERY EMAIL WITH A QUOTE,
QUOTE. OUR LIVES BEGIN TO END
THE DAY WE BECOME SILENT ABOUT
THE THINGS THAT MATTER. END
QUOTE. QUOTING DOCTOR MARTIN
LUTHER KING, SHE, IS SURVIVED BY
BRIDGET MATA AND PETER MATA, AND
THEY'VE JOINED US HERE TODAY IN
THE GALLERY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR JOINING US TODAY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO, HER STEPSON JIM, HER
STEPDAUGHTER RENEE, HER BROTHER
PAUL, AND SISTER, DEBBIE HAFNER,
AND GRANDKIDS, NICHOLAS AND
JACKIE MATA. TODAY AS I
MENTIONED, WE HAVE THE HONOR OF
BOTH OF THEM, BOTH BRIDGET AND
PETER BEING IN THE GALLERY,
THANK YOU FOR SHARING, MARTY
WITH ALL OF US HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND ORANGE COUNTY,
MR. PRESIDENT, I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN TODAY IN THE MEMORY OF
MARTY SCHRANK. THANK YOU. OUR
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO THE
FAMILY. AND THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US HERE TODAY. AND WE
ASK THAT YOU BRING HER NAME
FORWARD. SO SHE COULD. I'M
SORRY, SENATOR NEWMAN, ON THIS
ADJOURN IN MEMORY AND THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I, TOO, RISE TO
HONOR THE LIFE AND MEMORY OF
MARTY. MARTY AS MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED, WAS WAS AN ICON. SHE
WAS A UBIQUITOUS PRESENCE IN
ORANGE COUNTY, DEMOCRATIC PARTY
CIRCLES. IN ADDITION TO HER WORK
WITH THE COUNTY, WHICH DATES
BACK BEFORE ANY OF US WERE
INVOLVED, SHE WAS ALSO THE
EMINENCE GRISE OF MY LOCAL
DEMOCRATIC CLUB, THE DEMOCRATS
OF NORTH ORANGE COUNTY, MARTY,
COULD BE ORNERY, BUT OVER TIME,
THERE WAS NOBODY WHO DIDN'T COME
TO KNOW AND LOVE HER, BUT ALSO
RESPECT HER, FOR HER COMMITMENT.
YOU KNOW, CANDIDATE OR SPEAKER
EVER LEFT A MEETING OF THE
DEMOCRATS IN NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
WITHOUT BEING CLEAR ON WHERE
MARTY STOOD ON THEIR ISSUES? AND
OVER TIME, AS MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED, SHE HAD A MASSIVE
POSITIVE IMPACT ON SO MANY OF US
CANDIDATES, VOLUNTEERS, ANY OF
THE ANY OF THE ORGANIZATIONS
WORKING TO IMPROVE LIFE IN
ORANGE COUNTY, HER IMPACT AND
LEGACY WILL CARRY ON. WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO HAVE BRIDGET AND
PETER WITH US TODAY, AND I ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU AGAIN. OUR DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES AND WE ASK THAT YOU
BRING HER NAME FORWARD SO SHE
CAN BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN
THE SENATE JOURNAL. NEXT UP IS
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, AND GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN, COLLEAGUES.
TODAY I RISE IN THE MEMORY OF
THE GREAT REVEREND JAMES LAWSON,
OUR VERY OWN CIVIL RIGHTS
WARRIOR, BUT ONE OF THE GREATEST
CIVIL RIGHTS LEADERS TO APPEAR
ON THIS EARTH WHO PASSED AWAY
EARLIER THIS MONTH AT THE AGE OF
95. REVEREND LAWSON WAS MY
FRIEND AND THERE'S SO MUCH THAT
HAS BEEN SAID AND WRITTEN ABOUT
REVEREND LAWSON. BUT WHAT I KNOW
MOST ABOUT HIM IS JUST HIS
SPIRIT AND HIS SOUL. AND NO
MATTER WHO YOU WERE, WHETHER YOU
WERE A STUDENT OR A GOVERNOR,
REVEREND JAMES LAWSON MADE TIME
TO TEACH, TO TEACH AND TO SHARE
HIS WISDOM, TO LEND A LITTLE BIT
OF HIS SOUL, FORCE WITH YOU. AND
SOMETIMES IT COULD BE
FRUSTRATING WHEN YOU WOULD CALL
HIS HOME AND YOU'D GET A BUSY
SIGNAL, BECAUSE REVEREND LAWSON
DIDN'T BELIEVE IN TWO WAYS. SO
YOU KNEW SOMEONE WAS GETTING
GOOD COUNSEL BECAUSE THAT BUSY
SIGNAL WOULD BE ON THE LINE, BUT
FOR MORE THAN HALF A CENTURY, Kò
REVEREND JAMES LAWSON SERVED AS
OUR NATION'S MOST INFLUENTIAL
SOCIAL JUSTICE LEADERS FROM
CALIFORNIA, WHERE HE SPENT MOST
OF HIS TIME IN THE FIELDS OF
JUSTICE. INFLUENCED BY THE WORK
OF MAHATMA GANDHI, HE DEDICATED
HIS LIFE TO TEACHING
NONVIOLENCE, RESISTANCE, AND HE
BELIEVED IN THE USE OF PEACEFUL
YET POWERFUL TOOLS. THE SCIENCE
OF NONVIOLENCE. RECOGNIZING THAT
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE AND FORCE
COULD NOT BRING ABOUT THE
TRANSFORMATIVE CHANGE THAT OUR
WORLD SO NEEDED. HE TAUGHT THAT
WE HAD TO FIND THE HUMANITY IN
OUR ENEMY, AND WE HAD TO BUILD
THE BASIS OF UNDERSTANDING THAT
WOULD CHANGE OUR ENEMY. TO SEE
WHAT IS RIGHT WITH THE WORLD,
AND TO JOIN FORCES WITH THE
MORAL AUTHORITY OF THE PEOPLE.
HE BECAME A KEY ARCHITECT AND
STRATEGIST OF THE 1960S CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT, WORKING
ALONGSIDE DOCTOR KING TO FIGHT
AGAINST RACISM AND
DISCRIMINATION, AND THE TWO MEN
MET AS YOUNG MINISTERS IN 1957.
DOCTOR KING HAD JUST LED THE
SUCCESSFUL MONTGOMERY BOYCOTT
AND REVEREND LAWSON HAD JUST
RETURNED FROM INDIA AFTER HE HAD
SPENT ONE YEAR IN FEDERAL
PENITENTIARY AS A CONSCIENTIOUS
OBJECTOR AND RESISTING THE
DRAFT. HE AND DOCTOR KING
CONNECTED ON THE VALUE AND THE
POWER OF NONVIOLENCE, AND IN
THEIR CONVERSATIONS, DOCTOR KING
IMMEDIATELY TOLD REVEREND LAWSON
THAT HE NEEDED TO BRING HIS
KNOWLEDGE OF NONVIOLENT PRACTICE
TO THE SOUTH AND TO COME
IMMEDIATELY. AND REVEREND LAWSON
DID, AND HE BECAME A LEAD
TRAINER OF VOLUNTEERS AND
CAMPAIGN, STRATEGIST, WHERE HE
LED, IN THE NASHVILLE SIT INS,
VICTORY BY TRAINING HUNDREDS OF
YOUNG STUDENTS IN TENNESSEE ON
THE THEORIES OF NONVIOLENCE AND
THE PRACTICE OF CHANGE. AND IN
1960, THAT MOVEMENT SUCCESSFULLY
DESEGREGATED THE WOOLWORTH'S
COUNTER IN THE CITY OF NASHVILLE
AND INSPIRED A WHOLE NEW
GENERATION OF CIVIL RIGHTS
LEADERS IN THE SOUTH. IN 1968,
HE SERVED AS A PIVOTAL LEADER OF
THE MEMPHIS SANITATION STRIKE
AND WE REMEMBER HOW THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT BEGAN TO
TRANSITION INTO AN ECONOMIC
JUSTICE MOVEMENT. AND THE POOR
PEOPLE'S CAMPAIGN. AND IT WAS
REVEREND LAWSON THAT CALLED ON
REVEREND, KING TO COME DOWN TO
MEMPHIS TO BE A PART OF THE I AM
A MAN CAMPAIGN WHERE BLACKS
SANITATION WORKERS STOOD UP FOR
THEIR RIGHTS AND BECAME THE
RALLYING CRY FOR ALL LOW WAGE
WORKERS AND MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES TO HAVE THE DIGNITY
AT WORK AND THE POWER OF A
LIVING WAGE, AFTER HIS MOVE TO
CALIFORNIA, REVEREND LAWSON
BECAME A CENTRAL FIGURE IN THE
LABOR RIGHTS MOVEMENT OF LOS
ANGELES. AND THAT'S WHERE I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH HIM
AS WE WERE ORGANIZING SECURITY
OFFICERS WITH SEIU. AND I RECALL
REVEREND LAWSON COMING AND
TAKING A GROUP OF US TO LUNCH TO
TALK ABOUT THE CAMPAIGN. AND HE
EXPLAINED THE THEORIES OF
PLANTATION CAPITALISM AND HOW IT
IS ALIVE AND WELL IN OUR MODERN
DAY SOCIETY, WHERE THERE'S AN
OWNERSHIP SOCIETY THAT REFUSES
TO RECOGNIZE THE LABOR OF MEN
AND WOMEN AND THEIR NEED TO HAVE
DIGNITY IN THE WORKPLACE, AND
THAT EVEN IN THIS PLACE WHERE WE
WERE ORGANIZING AND IT SEEMED
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE, WHERE WE WERE
FACING SOME OF THE WEALTHIEST
LANDOWNERS IN LOS ANGELES, YOU
KNOW, HE SAID, THESE ARE NOTHING
MORE THAN VERTICAL PLANTATIONS.
AND WE HAVE TO LIBERATE AND FREE
ALL WORKERS. AND WE DO THAT
THROUGH UNIONIZATION, THROUGH
ORGANIZING AND LETTING THEIR
COLLECTIVE VOICES BE HEARD. AND
I REMEMBER ONE AFTERNOON WHEN WE
HAD WE WERE ALL ON THE STREETS
AND FOLKS WERE STARTING TO GET
ARRESTED, AND REVEREND LAWSON
WAS STANDING IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE STREET, A LIBRARY TOWER, AND
HE JUST STARTED TO PRAY IN THIS
POWERFUL WAY. AND THERE WAS A
BUILDING OWNER WHO OWNED A
NUMBER OF PROPERTIES IN DOWNTOWN
LA, AND HE CAME OUT OF THE
BUILDING IN THE MIDST OF THIS
PRAYER, AND REVEREND LAWSON
BROUGHT HIM OVER TO PRAY WITH
HIM. AND IT WAS ONE OF THE MOST
PROFOUND MOMENTS OF SEEING
TRANSFORMATION OF THE HUMAN
BEING BEFORE MY VERY EYES. AND
IT WAS A MAJOR BREAKTHROUGH. AND
THAT CAMPAIGN, WHICH WENT ON TO
ORGANIZE 4000 PRIVATE SECURITY
OFFICERS IN THESE DOWNTOWN
COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS. SO, YOU
KNOW, TO WITNESS THE POWER OF
REVEREND LAWSON'S HUMANITY
TOUCHING ANOTHER PERSON'S
HUMANITY AND MAKING IT BETTER
FOR THOUSANDS OF WORKERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES, REVEREND LAWSON
REALLY WAS, FOR ME, A SUPER HERO
AND A SOUL FORCE. THAT WAS JUST
UNDENIABLE, FROM HIS LEGACY AND
WORK WITH LOW WAGE WORKERS IN
THE HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY, THE
JANITORIAL INDUSTRY, THE
SECURITY INDUSTRY, THE FOOD AND
GROCERY WORKERS AS TO HIS
EDUCATION AND TEACHING AT THE
UCLA LABOR CENTER. NOW THE
REVEREND JAMES LAWSON, WORKER
CENTER WORKER, JUSTICE CENTER,
HE CARRIED SO MUCH WEIGHT BY
ARTICULATING STRATEGIES ROOTED
IN HIS INTELLECTUAL, THIRST FOR
TRUTH AND KNOWLEDGE AND STUDY,
BUT ALSO IN HIS LIVED EXPERIENCE
AS A WORLD CHANGER. I FELT
HONORED TO BE IN HIS PRESENCE. I
FELT HONORED TO GIVE HIM A RIDE
ANYWHERE. I FELT HONORED TO BE
ON A CALL. I FELT HONORED TO
HEAR HIS CALMING VOICE IN 2016,
WHERE HE SAID, AMERICA IS GOING
TO BE ALL RIGHT AND JUSTICE WILL
PREVAIL, AND THAT WE ARE PART OF
THAT JUSTICE. IN A WORLD RIFE
WITH TURMOIL, TURMOIL AND
INJUSTICE, REVEREND LAWSON, SOUL
FORCE AS A DIVINE PROBLEM SOLVER
WILL BE SO DEEPLY MISSED. I FEEL
THERE ARE NO MORE ADULTS LEFT IN
THE ROOM NOW. IT IS ON US. IT IS
ON US. AND HIS SPIRIT WILL LIVE
ON THROUGH THE CONTINUING CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT, THROUGH OUR
CONTINUING WORKERS RIGHTS
MOVEMENTS, THROUGH OUR
CONTINUING WORK, THROUGH WORKER
CENTERS AND LABOR CENTERS,
THROUGH THE WORK OF HOLMAN
UNITED METHODIST CHURCH, WHERE
HE WAS PASTOR FOR 25 YEARS. THAT
CONTINUES TO BE AN ADVOCATE FOR
JUSTICE THROUGH THE SOUTHERN
CHRISTIAN LEADERSHIP CONFERENCE
OF LOS ANGELES, WHICH HE HELPED
TO FOUND. AND THAT STANDS WITH
WORKING, WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR FOR
CRIMINAL FROM CRIMINAL JUSTICE
MOVEMENTS TO WOMEN'S RIGHTS
MOVEMENTS, AND TO THE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS MOVEMENT OF LOS ANGELES.
HE STOOD WITH AND STOOD UP FOR
SO MANY OF US. AND NOW IT IS OUR
TURN TO STAND UP AND BE A PART
OF HIS LEGACY. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY CALL FOR HIM TO BE
ENTERED INTO THE MEMORY OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. THANK
YOU. I'LL RECOGNIZE SENATOR
BRADFORD ALSO ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND I
JUST WANT TO QUICKLY ADD MY
VOICE IN THE ADJOURNMENT OF NOT
ONLY A CIVIL RIGHTS ICON, BUT A
LEGEND IN OUR OWN TIME, AN
INDIVIDUAL. WHEN YOU SAY
WARRIOR, A TRUE JEDI WARRIOR, A
WARRIOR FOR JUSTICE, EQUITY,
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION. AND I
AM BLESSED TO HAVE CALLED DOCTOR
LAWSON NOT ONLY A MENTOR, BUT A
FRIEND. BUT I FIRST MET HIM NOT
AS A CIVIL RIGHTS ICON, BUT AS A
FATHER, BECAUSE HIS SON, JOHN
LAWSON AND I MET IN COLLEGE AND
WE'VE AFFECTIONATELY CALLED HIM
JOHNNY LAW BECAUSE HE'S ONE OF
THE BRIGHTEST LAWYERS WE HAVE.
AND LÀ, IF NOT CALIFORNIA. BUT I
GOT TO SEE THE FATHER FIRSTHAND.
I GOT TO SEE THE HUSBAND
FIRSTHAND. I GOT TO SEE THE
MENTOR AND NOT JUST THE PREACHER
OF THE WORD, BUT A TEACHER OF
THE WORD. REVEREND LAWSON MADE
THE BIBLE PLAIN. HE ARTICULATED
THE WORDS OF GOD BETTER THAN
PROBABLY ANYBODY ELSE. BUT AT
THE SAME TIME, AGAIN, A FEARLESS
WARRIOR FOR JUSTICE AND EQUALITY
WHO WOULD STAND UP AND SPEAK
TRUTH TO POWER REGARDLESS OF
WHERE HE IS. AND AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES HIGHLIGHTED, IT
WAS REVEREND LAWSON WHO CALLED
DOCTOR KING TO MEMPHIS DURING
THE SANITATION STRIKE. HE SAYS
HE WAS THE CHIEF STRATEGIST ON
THAT STRIKE. MANY PEOPLE CREDIT
DOCTOR KING, BUT IT WAS DOCTOR
LAWSON WHO ORGANIZED THAT
STRIKE. IT WAS DOCTOR LAWSON
THAT ORGANIZED MANY OF THE EARLY
CITIZENS THROUGHOUT THE SOUTH,
AND HE ALSO ORGANIZED THE
FREEDOM RIDES. AND IT WAS IN
1989 WHEN I WAS BLESSED TO JOIN
MARTIN LUDLOW AND TAKE ALMOST 40
SOMETHING YOUNG KIDS FROM LOS
ANGELES AND RECREATE THE FREEDOM
RIDE EVERY STOP ALONG THE WAY.
AND DOCTOR LAWSON WAS ONE OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO EDUCATED US ON
WHAT TO EXPECT, HOW TO BE
PREPARED AND JUST TO EXPERIENCE
HIS FIRSTHAND EXPERIENCE TO IT
AND I GUARANTEE YOU IT WAS A
LIFE CHANGING EXPERIENCE FOR ME,
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, FOR ALL
THE YOUNG KIDS THAT WERE ON THAT
TRIP, IN CELEBRATION OF THE 25TH
ANNIVERSARY OF GOODMAN, CHANEY
AND SCHWERNER AND THEIR FAMILIES
JOINED US AS WELL, IN THAT
VENTURE. BUT IT WAS REVEREND
LAWSON AGAIN WHO JUST ENCOURAGED
US ALL TO KNOW THE TRUTH AND BE
COURAGEOUS AND BE FEARLESS, BUT
ALSO BE RESPECTFUL OF ONE
ANOTHER. AGAIN, AS MY COLLEAGUE
STATED, HE STUDIED UNDER GANDHI
AND HE INSTILLED THE NONVIOLENT
MOVEMENT IN THE SCLC AND THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT OF THE
60S. AND, ALTHOUGH HE RETIRED IN
1999, HE CONTINUED HIS WORK TO
CARE ABOUT EQUITY AND JUSTICE,
NOT ONLY HERE IN CALIFORNIA, NOT
ONLY IN THE UNITED STATES, BUT
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD. HE WAS AN
AMAZING EDUCATOR AND TEACHER. HE
GAVE HIS TIME AND HIS VOICE AND
PASSION TO CONTINUE THE FIGHT
FOR WORKERS, LGBTQ COMMUNITY,
AND THE REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS OF
WOMEN. AND I AM PROUD TO WORK
WITH MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE
SENATE. SENATOR D'ARAZZO, TO
HELP SECURE $15 MILLION IN 2021
FOR THE JAMES LAWSON LABOR
CENTER AT UCLA. AND I REMEMBER
THE JOY THAT DAY WHEN WE DID THE
DEDICATION. AND HE GIVEN ME A
HUG AND, YOU KNOW, AND THANKING
US. BUT IT WAS REALLY US WHO WAS
THANKING HIM FOR ALL THAT HE HAS
DONE THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE. AND SO
I'M DEEPLY HEARTBROKEN AT HIS
PASSING. AGAIN, A LOVING
HUSBAND, A FATHER, A CIVIL
RIGHTS ICON WHO IMPACTED THE
NATION AND THE WORLD. AND HE
WILL BE SORELY MISSED. BUT
MEMBERS, PLEASE JOIN ME IN AN
ADJOURNMENT OF JAMES MOORE
LAWSON, JUNIOR. THANK YOU,
SENATOR BRADFORD. SENATOR SMALL,
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME UP SO WE
CAN MOVE PROPERLY. MEMORIALS. OH
WE HAVE ONE MORE ON THIS ADJOURN
. GO AHEAD, SENATOR ROSS. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I ALSO RISE
WITH GREAT SADNESS AND ASK THAT
YOU ALL JOIN US IN ADJOURNING IN
THE MEMORY OF OUR GREAT FRIEND,
THE LATE REVEREND JAMES LAWSON.
HE WAS A CIVIL RIGHTS LEADER,
ALL RIGHT. BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY,
HE WAS AN ADVOCATE AND A FIGHTER
FOR HUMAN DIGNITY, PERIOD. HE
WAS UNWAVERING IN HIS
DETERMINATION. HE LEFT A
PERMANENT MARK ON OUR SOCIETY.
HE'S NOT THE NAME THAT IS WELL
KNOWN. YOU KNOW, IN POPULAR
TERMS, BUT ANYONE WHO DID ANY
KIND OF MOBILIZE, HUSING AND
ORGANIZING IN THE LABOR MOVEMENT
OF LOS ANGELES OR IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, KNOWS WHAT HE DID. HE
WAS THE KEY LEADER. HE DEDICATED
HIS LIFE TO DISMANTLING
SEGREGATION. THAT WAS SOMETHING
THAT HE DID ALONGSIDE DOCTOR
KING. SO OVER THREE DECADES AGO,
I MET REVEREND LAWSON AND HE
HELPED US REBUILD THE LABOR
MOVEMENT IN LOS ANGELES. HE
DIDN'T COME OUT OF THE LABOR
MOVEMENT. HE JUST BELIEVED IN
THE VALUES OF THE LABOR
MOVEMENT. AND ALONG SIDE, MANY
OF YOU HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RENAME THE UCLA JAMES LAWSON,
WORKER JUSTICE CENTER, A
PERMANENT HOME IN HONOR OF OUR
NATIONAL HERO. THIS CENTER IS IN
THE HEART OF THE WORKING POOR.
IT'S IN OUR LATINO IMMIGRANTS
FACE EXPLOITATION, AS REFERRED
BY REVEREND LAWSON AS PLANTATION
CAPITALISM. HE'S THE ONLY PERSON
I KNOW WHO USES THAT TERM, BUT
IT VERY APTLY DESCRIBES WHAT IT
GOES ON EVERY SINGLE DAY. THE
KIND OF PEOPLE THAT REVEREND
LAWSON DEDICATED HIS LIFE TO
SERVE MEN AND WOMEN WHO ARE
DENIED THE MOST BASIC HUMAN
NEEDS LIKE HEALTH CARE, FOOD, A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS, EVEN
WHILE THEY WORK DAY IN AND DAY
OUT. THE COMMUNITY, AND I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF LEARNING FROM
HIM THE PRINCIPLES OF WINNING
CAMPAIGNS AND COALITION
BUILDING, THE PRINCIPLE THAT IS
MOST IMPACTFUL IS THAT YOU DO
THE MOST GOOD FOR THE MOST
PEOPLE WHEN YOU EMPOWER THEM TO
MAKE CHANGE FOR THEMSELVES. BUT
ALL OF THIS WAS BASED ON HUMAN
DIGNITY. I WAS PERSONALLY
IMPACTED BY REVEREND LAWSON IN
THE 80S. I LED A CHANGE IN THE
HOTEL AND RESTAURANT WORKERS
UNION LOCAL 11, THE PREDOMINANT
LATINO WORKERS WITH THE BACKBONE
OF A VERY PROSPEROUS HOSPITAL
INDUSTRY. BUT BECAUSE OF A WEAK
UNION LEADERSHIP, THE
HOUSEKEEPERS AND THE COOKS HAD
NO CHOICE BUT TO ACCEPT WHATEVER
THE BOSSES GAVE THEM. WE SET OUT
TO CHANGE THAT. WE KNEW THE
WORKERS HAD TO BE EMPOWERED.
WELL, I ADMIT I WAS SCARED. THE
WORKERS WERE SCARED. WE HAD NO
EXPERIENCE IN TAKING ON POWERFUL
FORCES, POWERFUL NATIONAL
CORPORATIONS. THEN REVEREND
LAWSON STEPPED IN TO OUR LIVES.
ONE OF OUR MY MOST EXTRAORDINARY
MOMENTS WAS WHEN REVEREND LAWSON
JOINED CESAR CHAVEZ IN A MEETING
THAT WE HAD WITH HUNDREDS OF
HOTEL WORKERS AND WE HAD DONE
EVERYTHING WE COULD THINK OF
OVER SEVERAL YEARS TO WIN A NEW
FAIR CONTRACT. WE WERE LOSING
HOPE, TRUTH BE TOLD. BUT THE TWO
MOST POWERFUL TEACHERS OF NON
VIOLENCE IN THE NATION SPOKE
ABOUT HOW ORDINARY PEOPLE ACTED
IN EXTRAORDINARY WAYS TO WIN
THEIR BATTLES. POOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN SANITATION WORKERS IN
THE SOUTH AND POOR LATINO
FARMWORKERS IN DELANO,
CALIFORNIA. THEY INSPIRED US TO
STAY THE COURSE. WE DID AND WE
WON. WE LOST CESAR, BUT WE HAD
THE EXTRAORDINARY FORTUNE OF
HAVING REVEREND LAWSON CONTINUED
TO BE OUR GUIDING LIGHT IN THE
MOMENTS OF DESPAIR. HE WAS OUR
TEACHER TEACHINGS THAT LED
HOUSEKEEPERS TO MAKE BEDS IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE STREET AND THE
INTERSECTION OF FIFTH AND
FIGUEROA, AND THEN TURN AROUND
AFTER THEY WERE ARRESTED AND
ENGAGE IN CONVERSATION WITH THE
VERY POLICE THAT HAD ARRESTED
THEM. WE FILLED EVERY SEAT IN A
NICE RESTAURANT AND ORDERED
WATER FOR TWO HOURS AS A SHOW OF
SUPPORT TO THOSE WORKERS. THINK
ABOUT THIS AN ENGLISH SPEAKING
AFRICAN AMERICAN METHODIST FROM
PENNSYLVANIA TAUGHT SPANISH
SPEAKING MEXICAN AND CENTRAL
AMERICAN HOTEL WORKERS TO
ACHIEVE JUSTICE THROUGH STRIKES,
THROUGH MARCHES, THROUGH SIT
INS, THROUGH HUNGER FASTS AND
CIVIL DISOBEDIENCE. HIS
PHILOSOPHY TRANSFORMED US INTO
THE STRONGEST LABOR MOVEMENT IN
THE COUNTRY. HE TAUGHT JANITORS,
HOME CARE WORKERS, SECURITY
OFFICERS AND SUPERMARKET WORKERS
TO ENGAGE IN CAMPAIGN USING
NONVIOLENCE. HE TAUGHT BLACK,
BROWN, WHITE, ÁP HE TAUGHT ALL
WORKERS. HE TAUGHT US TO HELP
BUILD DOCTOR KING'S BELOVED
COMMUNITY, IN WHICH EVERYONE IS
CARED FOR, ABSENT OF POVERTY,
ABSENT OF HUNGER, AND ABSENT OF
HATE. HIS LONG LIFE OF ADVOCACY
WILL BE HONORED THROUGH THE
JAMES LAWSON WORKER JUSTICE
CENTER FOR DECADES TO COME. HE
TAUGHT SEVERAL GENERATIONS ON
THE SCIENCE AND THE PHILOSOPHY
OF NONVIOLENCE. AND LAST YEAR, I
WAS SO FORTUNATE TO INTRODUCE
AND WITH YOU ALL, WE PASSED A
BIPARTISAN, HISTORIC SENATE
RESOLUTION TO PROMOTE
NONVIOLENCE EDUCATION IN THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS OF CALIFORNIA.
THE JAMES LAWSON DOLORES HUERTA
NONVIOLENCE PROJECT WILL
TRANSFORM HIS NOBLE VISION INTO
REALITY. LET US CELEBRATE HIS
LIFE AND HIS INCREDIBLE IMPACT
ON OUR SOCIETY IN FRONT OF YOU.
YOU HAVE A BOOK ON THE TEACHINGS
OF REVEREND LAWSON ENTITLED
REVOLUTIONARY NONVIOLENCE. IT'S
OUR CONDOLENCES TO HIS WIFE,
DOROTHY WOOD LAWSON. HIS TWO
SONS, MAURICE AND JOHN, AND HIS
THREE GRANDCHILDREN. ON BEHALF
OF THOSE WORKERS WHOSE LIVES HE
CHANGED AND FOR THE STRENGTH AND
FRIENDSHIP HE GAVE TO ME. REST
IN PEACE, MY DEAR FRIEND.
REVEREND JAMES LAWSON. THANK YOU
ALL FOR THE POWERFUL COMMENTS.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS,
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME UP SO IT
CAN BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. IF
THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS.
SENATOR GROVE, THE DESK IS
CLEAR. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, WE ARE ADJOURNED FOR
TODAY. OUR NEXT FULLER SESSION
WILL BE THURSDAY, JUNE 20TH,
2024 AT 9 A.M. IT'S A BUSY WEEK
AND ENJOY YOUR TIME IN THE
SENATE. THE SENATE IS ADJOURNED.
WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY, JUNE
20TH AT 9 A.M.